[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRETT HESTERBERG:
Today we're going
to talk first a little
bit about the big picture,
and then we'll get into
building our application.
What we're going to
attempt to do today
is build a web app that is
fault tolerant and scalable.
And we're going to do it using
Kubernetes Engine and Cloud
SQL as our backend database.
What you see in this
diagram is that we're
going to opt to deploy
Kubernetes Engine and Cloud
SQL in two failure domains, in
multiple failure domains, where
these are represented
by Google Cloud zones
within a region, where a
zone is essentially a failure
domain within a region.
So we're going to deploy
these across zones.
We're going to see
how things scale.
And then we'll inject
some faults and kind
of simulate disaster
striking, so to speak.
Before we get there, we'll
do a little introduction
on Kubernetes Engine itself,
as well as Cloud SQL.
I think, by show
of hands at least,
there are a number of
folks in the audience who
haven't had experience
with Kubernetes Engine
and potentially
not with Cloud SQL.
ALLAN NALM: Yeah, thanks, Brett.
So back in the early
2000s, Google was off
indexing the whole
world wide web,
and its goal is
to build a service
at planetary scale, where
anyone around the world
basically can get a response
back in milliseconds, right?
But when you go back
12, 14 years ago,
Google was like any
company you see today.
Applications were built running
on top of infrastructure,
and there was this dependency on
the underlying infrastructure.
And we knew we needed to scale
and really scale quickly.
So we went off
and tried to solve
two very discrete problems.
Number one, how do
you take a workload
and deploy it on a machine
and do it predictably,
and then deploy a variety of
workloads on the same machine
so you get better efficiency?
And then how do you
take this machine
and attach it to
a pool of compute.
So as developers,
you just write code,
and you don't really care
where that application ends
up running, right?
That's what we went
off to solve back then.
And now is really the
advent of containers.
Google has been using
containers for many years--
over a decade.
Back in-- about 14 years ago, we
open sourced a lot of the work
around cgroups.
That really helped
running containers
in isolation and so forth.
So as you look at where Google
is today, everything at Google
actually runs inside a
container, all our services,
from Ads to Search.
A matter of fact,
for Google Cloud,
our virtual machines
are actually
running inside a container.
And we spin up over four
billion containers per week.
A lot of the work that we did
around containers really led
to the creation of an internal
system Google uses called Borg.
All of our developers
that write applications
submit their jobs to Borg.
And then Borg schedules
all these workloads
across Google's fleet.
A few years back, with
the advent of containers
and the popularity
of containers,
Google decided to take all
the various best practices
associated with running
and operating and managing
containers internally with Borg
and create this open source
project called Kubernetes.
And really, that was the
genesis behind Kubernetes
that we announced
around four years ago.
And we open sourced it.
And the goal of
Kubernetes is really
to manage and operate around
your container workloads,
right?
It was really inspired
by the best practices
that Google had around running,
managing, and operating
containers internally.
And the design premise
behind Kubernetes
is we wanted it to
run anywhere, right?
And that was really the goal
of basically open sourcing it.
And then working with
the community in terms
of providing support,
whether you're running it
on Google Cloud or running it
on any cloud, on bare metal,
on any virtualization
technology,
the whole goal
with Kubernetes is
just to make it
easy, open, flexible,
and basically the ability
to run it anywhere you want.
It was written in Go.
And as I mentioned, from day
one we open sourced this.
And the popularity of
Kubernetes right now
is it's become the
de facto standard
for running and managing
containers out in the market.
Really, the success is
behind the community
behind it and the API that it
brought forward to the world.
When you're getting
started with Kubernetes--
just a show of hands,
how many people attended
the keynote this morning?
Great.
So you've probably heard about
the announcements around GKE
and bringing the GKE experience
to on-prem and things
of that nature.
Before this announcement,
getting Kubernetes up
and running outside
of Google Cloud
really involved using a mix
and match of different tooling.
It was an inconsistent
experience,
depending on where
you're running it.
There are different tools.
And we went off and
tried to figure out,
how do we make this consistent?
But at Google, we have
this notion called
separation of concerns, right?
And although DevOps is a
very important function,
oftentimes when you give a
developer a double-edged sword,
where on one hand you're
asking them to write code,
and on the other hand
you're asking them to worry
about debugging,
troubleshooting, deployments,
it's not a very
optimal thing to do.
And at Google we have
different functions.
We have our
developers, and then we
have this specialization called
an application ops person.
And then we have
another specialization
called the cluster ops person.
And in the case of Kubernetes,
a cluster ops person
would come along and
create the environment.
That's your day zero, right?
And once you have this
environment up and running
and you're provisioned
on top of nodes,
and you've configured
networking,
and you've set up all
the various agents
and containerized
services in the cluster,
it's not a simple process.
And the cluster
administrator really
is focused on getting all
of that up and running.
From there, you basically
have now this API
that you can use to deploy
your containerized applications
in a consistent fashion.
And once that's available,
now the application ops person
can come along and deploy their
containerized applications
in such a way where it's
resilient, it's scalable,
and so forth.
So the role of
the developer ends
where the role of the
application ops person starts.
And the role of the
application person
stops where the role of
the cluster admin starts.
Now, you might be wondering, how
do I do all this in the cloud?
Well, at Google, we
introduced, three years ago,
a managed Kubernetes service
called Google Kubernetes
Engine.
It's been GA now
for three years.
It's very much
managed Kubernetes.
It's an API call to
create a cluster.
We're actually going to
show you demo of this.
Our demo's going to
go through everything
that we're talking about, and
we're going to do it live.
But it's really an API
call to create a cluster.
You specify how
many nodes you need.
You specify the region you want
your nodes, which zones you
want them deployed in.
You can specify a whole
bunch of other parameters
that we'll go through.
But that's it.
After a few minutes,
you have a cluster now.
And you have an API that you can
use to actually run and manage
your containerized applications.
On top of that,
Kubernetes Engine
provides you a
level of automation
around node auto-repair, right?
So your worker
nodes, where you're
running your applications,
every three months,
there's a new version
of Kubernetes.
And we basically manage--
give you the option
of specifying
if you want your nodes
auto-upgraded, if you
want your master auto-upgraded.
If there's an issue with one
of your nodes, we'll go in
and we'll repair the node.
There's integrated auto-scaling
with the underlying virtual
machines.
So you can configure
everything from your container
auto-scaling all the way down
to your node auto-scaling.
And again, we'll show you how
all that works in our demo.
BRETT HESTERBERG: With that,
let me ask the audience,
how many of you have experience
with Google Cloud SQL?
OK, about a third or so.
I'll give a little introduction.
And of course, you'll see this
as we begin to demonstrate
our application deployment.
Let me start by saying where
Cloud SQL fits in Google's
overall database portfolio.
The database portfolio
in Google Cloud
is large and ever-growing.
You see rightmost on the slide
a number of database offerings
from our partners.
Google Cloud has a
large partner ecosystem.
And we list here a handful
of database partners
who have offerings
on Google Cloud.
This is not an exhaustive list.
Leftmost on the slide you
see our in-memory database.
We pretty recently launched
a managed Redis service.
So if you have caching
needs, take a look
at Cloud Memorystore which
recently launched Redis
into beta.
Just right of center is our
relational portfolio comprised
of Cloud Spanner and Cloud SQL.
If you haven't taken a
look at Cloud Spanner,
there are a number
of talks going
on this week at the
conference, and I encourage you
to get to know that product.
Cloud SQL in the
relational portfolio
has one core commitment,
and that is compatibility.
We offer as close to unmodified
MySQL and Postgres as we can,
so that if your application
works with MySQL or Postgres,
it just works with Cloud SQL.
In today's demonstration,
we're going
to be using Cloud
SQL for Postgres.
But the compatibility
story is essentially
Cloud SQL's core promise.
In addition to
compatibility, Cloud SQL
aims to reduce mundane
database administration
tasks commonly associated with
running MySQL and Postgres.
When we think about the Cloud
SQL stack and what it can do,
I think Tim Kelton
from Descartes Labs
does a good job
of summing this up
in terms of how he
sees SQL for his team.
He notes here that his team's
using Cloud SQL at Descartes
Labs because it
allows them to focus
their time on other things,
things that more valuable
to them and to their customers.
When I tend to think
of the Cloud SQL stack,
I picture this diagram,
where this, in my mind,
is what it takes to run
a database yourself.
You have leftmost on
the slide a column
that shows essentially the
hardware, racking and stacking
of servers, thinking about power
and cooling for those servers.
As you move left, we get
to the operating system,
where we're worried about
installation and maintaining,
updating that operating system.
Continuing to move left, we
finally get to the database
itself.
We're installing that database.
We're keeping it patched.
We're keeping it secure.
We're setting up things
like regular backups
for data protection.
And finally, rightmost
in the slide,
we get into some
advanced kind of things.
We're talking about
here high availability,
setting up replication
for scale out,
making decisions about when
a database is unhealthy,
should we automatically
failover, failover manually?
And the breadth
of this stack, we
have to plumb this through
to some monitoring systems
so we can keep tabs
on our environment.
The goal of Cloud SQL is to
turn this technology stack
into an API call,
so that if you're
a DevOps engineer,
a developer, you
can set up, with a single API
call, a very simple development
database or a much more advanced
production database that
includes automatic failover
over for high availability
and replication
for read scale out.
Again, the goal here is
simplify this picture, such
that this turns into an
API or a few UI clicks,
as you'll see in our demo.
What isn't covered
on this slide,
and what's not shown
in this diagram,
is what backs Cloud SQL.
And Jason from RealMassive
points this out.
He notes that Cloud SQL, and
managed services generally
in Google Cloud, give him
and his team peace of mind
because they are backed by
dedicated 24-by-7 SRE teams.
For Cloud SQL, this is the
team writing the automation,
writing the monitoring
to make sure
that our fleet of
databases is healthy.
And when needed,
they're the folks
who get on the keyboard to
bring an unhealthy database back
to life.
Hopefully, that gives you just
a feel for what Cloud SQL is.
Let's now talk a little
less and start our building.
We'll remind everybody that
what we're building today
is a fairly simple
web application.
It's about 200 lines
of Python code.
The language doesn't
matter so much.
We're taking a web application
that we'll test and then
finally deploy here in a way
that uses Kubernetes Engine
and Cloud SQL to make
sure it's both fault
tolerant and scalable.
Again, the picture
here illustrates
that we're going to span our
application across two zones
so that we're fairly
fault tolerant.
And if all goes
well, we're going
to throw some faults at it.
Before we get into
this, I want to note
two additional key
components we're using.
We've talked a lot about
Kubernetes Engine and Cloud
SQL.
We're going to be introducing
the notion of the Cloud SQL
proxy.
And what you see in this
diagram is the proxy
is a client-side installable
that makes your Cloud SQL
database look local.
So if you were to install
the proxy on your laptop,
and you fired it up at
your favorite coffee shop,
your Cloud SQL
database would appear
to be local on that laptop.
The Cloud SQL proxy
behind the scenes
is setting up a secure tunnel
to your database automatically.
And to the application
that you're developing,
you can act like, or
make it believe, that you
are running a local database.
And you'll see that in the demo.
This is really important
for Kubernetes Engine
because what we're going to be
starting up pods and bringing
them down rapidly.
And we want to make
sure that we don't
have to deal with things like
white-listing IP addresses
on a firewall.
We let the proxy do all
that sort of authentication
and connection for us.
The other key concept here
is Google Cloud Shell.
How many of you have
used Google Cloud Shell?
That's great.
So about half the room.
That's actually more
than we thought.
We joke that
sometimes Cloud Shell
is one of our best
kept secrets in GCP.
Cloud Shell is a VM that you
get for free, provisioned to you
with your Google Cloud account.
We're going to be using it today
as our development environment
because it includes a lot of
useful tools for a variety
of languages, including Python.
It also includes a
Docker environment
that we're going to use as
we start to build and test
our application.
OK, with that, Allan, let's get
into the actual build itself.
We're going to start with
a Cloud SQL instance.
And so you see my project here.
And we can adjust the font
as needed so folks can see.
I'm going to start by
creating a Cloud SQL instance.
And let me just zoom
in a little bit.
When you're creating
a Cloud SQL instance--
I'm going to choose
Postgres in this case--
we answer a few fairly
straightforward questions.
We'll say this is
our instance name.
I knew I'd typo right away.
All right, this is
our instance name.
I'm going to use a password
that I highly do not recommend.
You can all see it here.
This is way short and very
prone to dictionary attack.
Please don't use this.
We're going to deploy Cloud
SQL and Kubernetes Engine
in US central.
Obviously, you can deploy
it in any region you'd like.
And I'm going to pick Zone B,
as in Bravo, for our instance.
Now let's ask Cloud
SQL to take care
of some administration for us.
As a starting point, I'm
going to size Cloud SQL here.
Cloud SQL starts at very
small, inexpensive instances,
less than $10 a month, if
you haven't used Cloud SQL.
And it scales way up right
now to 64 core machines.
This number is ever increasing.
You'll see higher
numbers in the future.
But for today, we'll give Cloud
SQL, say, eight compute cores.
And we'll max out
RAM, which is always
a good idea for our database.
We expect some traffic
on our web application.
The nice thing
about Cloud SQL is
you can change
these at any time.
We can scale up later or
scale back down if we need to.
One thing that's a bit
less intuitive when
I'm thinking about scaling
Cloud SQL or starting it up
is scaling my
storage performance.
In Google Cloud
and in Cloud SQL,
performance to scale by
adding storage capacity.
And you see that Cloud
SQL includes a performance
calculator here, which
right now is showing me
that we just have a sliver
of the performance we could
get for our instance here.
I can increase that performance
by increasing capacity.
And I'll give it a little
more because, again, we
think our web app is
going to be a popular one.
I mentioned that Cloud SQL aims
to help manage mundane database
administration tasks.
And a good example is the
automatic storage increase.
This is a simple checkbox
in the Create flow.
What it does is tell Cloud SQL,
hey, keep an eye on my disk.
Make sure I don't run
out of disk space.
Before I do, increase
it a little bit
and continue to do so that I
don't run out of disk space.
This, I think, is
a great example
of what we're talking about when
we say managing the mundane.
I'll leave this checked
so that, just in case,
we don't run out of disk
today during the demo.
As we look a bit more,
we'll ask Cloud SQL
to automate our backups.
We'll have it do so
pretty late at night
to keep it out of the way of our
production runs during the day.
And as a key point, I'm going
to tell Cloud SQL that we
want to be highly available.
When I do this, Cloud
SQL gets the message
that it has some
extra work to do
to make sure that this instance
is a bit more fault tolerant.
OK, with those
options selected, I'm
not going to bother
authorizing any networks.
We're going to let the Cloud
SQL handle our connection
security for us.
And I won't bother setting
up any more configuration.
We'll just go ahead and
create our instance.
A Cloud SQL instance takes
about three minutes to create.
So fortunately for
all of you, I have,
very Martha Stewart style,
one fresh from the oven
ready for us to use.
And with that-- thank you, by
the way, for the few laughs.
With that, I'm going to fire
up Cloud Shell, as I mentioned,
one of, potentially,
our best kept secrets.
And let's get to
developing our application.
As Cloud Shell
comes up, remember,
this is the VM
that's provisioned
for you in your project.
It comes with a number
of tools built in.
I've done just a little
bit of setup work.
What I did was install
the Cloud SQL proxy
and set up a service account
so that I can authenticate
or connect to any Cloud
SQL instance in my project.
So let me go ahead and
start up the proxy.
And then I'll show you what
a connection looks like.
OK, so we'll start up the proxy.
This looks good.
And then I'm going to go ahead
and connect using Cloud Shell's
built-in Posgres client.
And what you'll
notice here as I type
this command is that I'm
going to tell my Cloud Shell
VM that the database
is running locally.
You see that I'm using
localhost as the address.
When I do that, the Cloud
SQL proxy intercepts,
and it asks for
my password, which
I'll put in my very
secure password here.
And we've connected here.
Let me make sure that we
have an empty database.
We just created this
database, so let's make sure.
Let's ask Postgres
if it's empty.
Whoops.
OK, Postgres says
I've got nothing
in my tables, no tables at
all, which is a good thing.
We've got a brand new
database, and we're
ready to use it for
our application.
What you've seen here is that
I've got good connectivity now
from my Cloud Shell
VM to my database.
So with that, let's
get our app started.
One of the things
to note-- you're
more than welcome to take
pictures as we go along.
Everything Allan and I do today
is captured in a public code
lab, so you can go
through this yourself
when you're ready
on your own PC.
What I will show you
is the application
that we've pre-built for
you as part of the code lab.
As I mentioned, it's a Python
application, a pretty small web
app.
And I'll download it
now to our Cloud Shell.
This is hosted
right now on GitHub.
And again, it's available for
you as part of the code lab.
We're writing this
application in Python,
but the language itself
doesn't matter as much.
For those who are
familiar with Python,
I'm going to go ahead and set up
a virtual environment so we can
get our development started.
And we will also then go ahead
and activate the environment
before we can get some
necessary modules downloaded,
some dependencies
for our application.
So I've got my
environment activated now.
Let me go get some dependencies.
The pre-built app comes
with a requirements list
that you'll see as
one of the files.
And I can go and pip install
a bunch of dependency modules.
For those who are familiar
with Python and web frameworks,
you'll notice that most of
these dependencies are Flask.
We're running a
Flask web app today.
So we've downloaded these.
Let's go ahead and
test our application.
So I'm going to
launch this directly
within the Cloud Shell VM.
And a really useful
feature here is
that Cloud Shell builds in a
local web host environment.
So I can test my web application
right here from the Cloud VM.
Let's bring this up.
And what you see is
our app is at least
deployed as a test application.
We're creating a Meme
Gen application, which
is very important at Google.
And I will go ahead and
create the first meme.
Let me put in our meme here.
We'll see if our application can
happily talk to our database.
And there we go.
We've got our first
meme of the day.
Let me navigate back.
We'll just see that
the app's working.
We should just have
our one meme in Recent.
OK, so we know now
our application
is working, at least
for test purposes.
Let's navigate back
to our Cloud Shell
where I will go ahead and
kill our web host real quick
So now, if I look at our
other tab and I do a refresh,
we should see, yep,
our web app is down.
So we don't have our
test running anymore,
which is great.
What we're going to do now
is start to use Docker.
We're going to containerize
our application now
that we've tested it and
know that it's running.
What you see here is
that our Cloud Shell VM
has some Docker tools built in.
And I'm creating now a
container that we will go ahead
and deploy using Docker within
our Cloud Shell VM as a way
to test again and get ready
for our deployment to GKE.
As this is building,
Allan, can you
talk a little bit
about the general steps
to take an application like
we have now and get it to GKE?
ALLAN NALM: Yeah,
so the first step
is containerizing
the application.
Once it's containerized,
we're going
to push the image into
Google Container Registry.
And Google Container Registry
is the private repo for you
to store your container images.
Keep in mind that you can use
Google Container Registry not
only for Google Kubernetes
Engine or Google Cloud,
but you can use it from
outside Google Cloud as well.
So once this image is stored
in Google Container Registry,
we'll then be in a position
to specify and build
our Kubernetes
manifest to go pull
from Container
Registry the images
that we want
deployed in our pods.
BRETT HESTERBERG: That's great.
So it looks like our
container has built.
I'm going to go ahead and run
it in Docker in our Cloud Shell
VM.
We've got that running.
And what this should mean
is that as I navigate back
to our test, or our local web
app, if I refresh this app,
we've now containerized
the application.
And ideally, this should work.
There's is our Meme Gen back.
We stored our first meme
in the Cloud SQL database,
so it's been persisted.
And we have a live
containerized web app.
Let me navigate back
to our Cloud Shell
where we can stop our
Docker image here.
And we'll get a
little bit of cleanup
done before, now, we get
ready to move to Kubernetes.
So we've tested our application.
We containerized it.
Now, as Allan said,
we can start to get
to the fun part, which is let's
get this deployed to Kubernetes
Engine.
Let me go ahead and stop
our Docker runtime here.
There we go.
And we'll just double
check that indeed, yep,
we've got this turned off.
OK, so let me kill off this tab.
I'm going to also stop
or Cloud SQL proxy.
So we've gotten
cleaned up here, Allan.
Let me now start to get ready
to deploy our application.
ALLAN NALM: All right,
now comes the fun part.
So we're actually going to go in
and create a Google Kubernetes
Engine cluster.
BRETT HESTERBERG: And so
as part of this, Allan,
we're starting to set
up a bit of credentials.
And we're going to get ready
to deploy first our image
to Container Registry.
ALLAN NALM: Yes.
So what's happening
here is we're
tagging the image that
we're going to push
into Container Registry.
And then we're going
to issue a command
to push this image into GCR
with those associated tags.
And then the step before that
was really giving the Docker
runtime the credentials
to be able to communicate
with Google Container Registry.
BRETT HESTERBERG:
So what you see here
is we have a Container
Registry that's empty.
This is a new project for us.
We don't have anything
that we've uploaded
to Container Registry yet.
But let's change that right now.
And we'll start the push
to Container Registry.
Allan, as this starts
to work, can you
tell us, in general, what's
the benefit of using Container
Registry?
ALLAN NALM: Right.
So Container Registry's
really a secure way for you
to store your images,
and it can integrate
with any CI/CD tooling that's
available today on the market.
It gives you
consistent experience
for managing the lifecycle
of your container images.
And as I mentioned earlier, this
is not just a Google Kubernetes
Engine service.
You can use it from pretty
much anywhere outside
of Google Kubernetes
Engine, including
outside of Google Cloud.
We've done a bunch of work
around giving you the ability
to sign images, really
have at-the-station steps
around the lifecycle of images
coming out of Google Container
Registry.
So it's really about giving you
that consistent and verifiable
and secure way of running
and managing your images
as you look at pushing them
into different environments.
BRETT HESTERBERG:
And I think, yeah,
the important
point you mentioned
there is that while
Container Registry is very
useful for using
Google Cloud products,
it can also be useful when
you're managing things well
outside of Google Cloud.
ALLAN NALM: Correct, yes.
BRETT HESTERBERG: OK, so we're
close now to getting this
pushed to our
Container Registry.
Let's see as this command
finishes up if, indeed, we
have this uploaded.
We've got our Meme Gen app.
And let's just
take a quick look.
Looks like we
uploaded it just now.
OK, great.
Next step then, Allan,
is to actually create
our Kubernetes cluster.
And before I do that,
we'll just double check.
I don't think we've created
anything in this project
before.
Looks like we've got a pretty
brand new project here.
Let me go ahead and
issue this command.
And as this is running,
let's talk through a few
of these parameters.
I'll bring up the UI.
One thing to note here is
that while we are pretty CLI
heavy in this demonstration,
all of these things
can be done via a
UI, or even an API,
depending on your preference.
I'll go ahead and
bring up the UI
so we can talk through
a few of the parameters.
ALLAN NALM: Great.
So what we're doing
here is we're actually
creating a Kubernetes
cluster that spans
multiple availability zones.
So think of an availability
zone as a fault domain, right?
And the whole goal here is our
nodes will span availability
zones, so when we
deploy or applications,
the replicas of the application
will be across the region.
So this gives us higher
availability and resiliency
for our application.
And let's just walk through
some of the configurations
associated with the cluster.
When you go and create a
cluster, by default it's zonal.
So your control plane
and the worker nodes
will all be in the same zone.
But you have an option
to change it to regional.
And when you change
it to regional,
you now have the ability for
your control plane, which
is your master, to be
replicated across three
zones within the region.
And then you specify
how many nodes you want
for this particular cluster.
And then those
nodes get deployed
across the various zones
within that particular region.
I mentioned earlier that
Google Kubernetes Engine,
having been a GA product
for three years now,
we feel like we have the most
sophisticated, most mature
managed Kubernetes
offering out there
on the market across any cloud.
Typically, when there's a
new version of Kubernetes
out there released
every three months,
Google Kubernetes
Engine has support
for that upstream version
within a couple of weeks.
So part of the process
is you basically
specify how many CPUs you
want for each machine type.
By default, the node
operating system
is Container-Optimized OS.
This is a Chromium-based
operating system
that's very secure that Google
has created, Google maintains.
If you want more flexibility
from a host operating system
standpoint, we also
provide support for Ubuntu.
Now, if you scroll
down a bit more,
you provide information
around how many
nodes you want in your
particular cluster.
And that's really around
the day zero experience.
Now, there's a whole bunch of
parameters really associated
with the day one experience.
So you can specify,
for example, I
want Google to
automatically upgrade
my nodes when there's
a new version,
or I want to be notified.
If something happens
to a particular node,
it fails, I'd like
Google Kubernetes Engine
to basically repair that
node and fix that node.
Same thing with patching,
all that is very--
we have an SRE team that
basically manages the services.
And if anything happens
to your cluster,
that SRE team will
fix the problem.
There's built-in integration
with Stackdriver logging
and monitoring.
Scroll down, click on More.
You can label your cluster.
You can assign additional
zones that you want your nodes
to be distributed across.
There's auto-scaling not
only at the pod level,
but at the node level.
So you can integrate with the
underlying managed instance
group framework for
Google Compute Engine
to initiate an out-of
scale from your pod level
all the way down to
your cluster level.
So we would add additional
nodes to your cluster
if there's resource contention.
You can configure persistent
disk storage to your cluster
and basically map the
persistent disk resources,
depending on where your
pods are running, which
zone that they're running in.
And then one of the really cool
features of Google Kubernetes
Engine is the integration
with Cloud networking.
The fact that Google Cloud
networking is a global service,
you can assign a
VPC to your cluster.
And that cluster
now has the ability
to take advantage
of a global network
from a backbone standpoint.
So you can actually
have clusters
that are running in
different regions that
are using the same VPC that can
actually talk to each other.
Pods can talk to each other.
That's a very cool
feature that's
only available in Google Cloud.
BRETT HESTERBERG: Those
are great points, Allan.
And we picked out a few
parameters specifically
for this demonstration.
But I think walking
through the UI
here shows some of the
flexibility you get
when you're creating clusters.
Again, if you're
new to Kubernetes,
have a pass at our code lab.
We think we've picked
a few good options,
but obviously there are
more to choose from.
It looks like, Allan, our
cluster has been created.
I see now it now in the UI.
ALLAN NALM: Yep, so can you
click on Compute Engine?
BRETT HESTERBERG: Yeah.
Let's take a look
here because you
mentioned that underpinning
all of this are a set of VMs.
ALLAN NALM: Yes.
So you see these VMs
now that are created?
There are six in total.
And they're created.
There's two in each zone.
So this gives you the resiliency
now for your application
so that your application
can be scheduled.
Depending on how many
replicas you specify,
they'll be scheduled
across the availability
zones for the cluster.
BRETT HESTERBERG: OK,
so let's continue on.
We promised some
scalability, et cetera.
Let's get this started
to set up here.
ALLAN NALM: So the next
thing we're going to do
is we're going to get the
credentials for that cluster,
and we're going to store
it in our kubeconfig file.
It's a local file.
So what kubeconfig
does is it provides--
Kubernetes has a
command line interface
that comes with the project
called kube control,
or kubectl.
So once you have
the credentials,
you can now use kube control
to manage your cluster
and basically operate against
any of the APIs, the Kubernetes
APIs that are available.
And that's what
we're going to do.
From here forward, we're
going to use kube control
to manage and operate and deploy
applications on our cluster.
BRETT HESTERBERG:
That's a great point.
I'll get started
with kube control
by setting up a couple secrets.
I'm going to set up
two secrets here.
The first will be to make
sure that our application can
use the Cloud SQL proxy to
connect to our Cloud SQL
instance.
The second secret,
you'll notice,
is my username and
database password,
so that our
application can log in.
So we've got our two
secrets created here.
What I have done
before we started
was modify the YAML
file that we're
going to use for deployment.
So let me just get the new
YAML file put in place here.
And then we can take a quick
look at the YAML file, Allan,
just to show folks what
what's inside of this one.
ALLAN NALM: Yeah, so this
is a deployment file.
This is a Kubernetes
artifact, right.
It's a specification that
you define that describes
your application.
And what we're doing
here is we are deploying
a pod that contains the
[? Meme ?] Gen container, as
well as the Cloud SQL proxy
as a sidecar container.
So a pod is really about
packaging containers
together that have very much
a dependency on each other,
right?
So any time you have
multiple containers
that need to live
and die together,
or perhaps need to share
local IPC or share storage,
you put those in a pod.
And it becomes a unit of scale.
When you create a
pod in Kubernetes,
every pod is assigned
an IP address.
So we have this
notion of IP per pod.
And these are internal addresses
that are basically pulled out
of the CIDR block
ranges that are
assigned for every node
within a Kubernetes cluster.
By default, every node
gets a slash 24 CIDR range.
And when a pod comes up
on that particular node,
it takes an IP from that range.
BRETT HESTERBERG: That's great.
So I just used our YAML
file to start the creation.
And what we'll look
for is that our pods
get created as
we'd expect, as you
mentioned, with two containers.
ALLAN NALM: Correct.
So think of a deployment as a
Kubernetes controller, right?
So with the
deployment, Kubernetes
brings this notion of
a declarative model.
So within a deployment, you
specify your desired state,
what you'd like the world to
look like for your application,
so how many instances.
You can specify certain
labeling associated
with your application.
A controller is constantly
monitoring the actual state
of your application.
So if something bad
happens, a node goes down,
a pod goes down, the controller
will look at the actual state
and then will compare
with the desired state
that you specify in
that deployment file,
and will always ensure that
your actual state equals
your desired state.
This is the beauty
in terms of being
able to deploy an
application that's
highly available,
resilient, and not
have to worry
about ensuring that
the application, the
number of instances.
If something goes
wrong, Kubernetes
is will always kick
in with health checks
to ensure that your actual
state equals to that state
that your application needs.
BRETT HESTERBERG: It's really
a notion of infrastructure
by configuration
file in this case.
ALLAN NALM: Yep.
So what we're doing
now is we talked
about the whole notion of a pod
gets an internal IP address.
But let's say you want
that pod to be accessed
from the outside world.
And what Brett just did
is exposed the deployment
as a load balance service.
So what this actually does
it creates a service object,
and it creates a
GCE load balancer,
assigns it an
external IP address,
and creates the
routes associated
with that external
IP address back
to the pods, the
internal pods, that
are running in your cluster.
In our case here, we only
had one pod that was running.
But think of a case where
you have 10 pods running
across multiple machines.
Once you hit that
external IP, they'll
get round-robined to the
appropriate pods running
across your cluster.
So as you can see here, we
have an external IP address
that's been assigned.
And Brett can now hit it.
And basically, it should
show the application.
And for those of you
that have phones and want
to hit that address,
please go in and meme.
BRETT HESTERBERG: Yeah,
I think this is really
the moment of truth.
We're going to find
out right now if we
deployed this app publicly.
It looks like on our end
that this app is good.
We're going to double
check our database here.
Looks like our lone
meme is still there.
So as Allan
mentioned, if you have
mobile devices and a
pretty good set of eyes
here to read this URL--
we can read it out to you.
Let me zoom this in, if we want.
Here, let's just see.
I'm struggling to
zoom the IP address.
I will read it quickly--
35.226.10.149.
I suspect there are many
great memes in this audience,
far better than mine.
And to sweeten the
deal a bit, Allan
and I have come armed with $500
Google Cloud credit coupons.
We're happy to dole
those out to folks
who create some
of the best memes
and hit us up after the event.
One thing I will note
here is that this session
is being recorded and will
be broadcast on the internet.
So let's please keep the
memes as tasteful as we can.
But I look forward to seeing
what you come up with.
We talked to Allan at the
beginning about auto-scaling,
or about building a
scalable application.
Let's start to
add an auto-scaler
to our configuration.
And then we'll see if,
between the audience and maybe
ourselves, we can
generate some load.
ALLAN NALM: Let's do that.
BRETT HESTERBERG: All right.
And I'm looking forward,
by the way to-- whoa.
Some of the memes coming in.
We're going to go
back to that tab.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so we just added
an auto-scaler.
ALLAN NALM: Yeah, so what
we're doing right now
is we're creating a horizontal
pod auto-scaler object.
And what this does is it defines
a certain set of thresholds.
So what we're
doing here is we're
saying, if the combined CPU
utilization across all my pods
increases above 50%, I'd
like you to auto-scale.
So if we take a look at
our HPA object right now,
there's really no load.
BRETT HESTERBERG: There's
no load at this point.
We should really see this
number at almost close to zero.
So we'll let this get
it initialized here.
And then, oh, it
looks like we've
got a little bit of load,
courtesy of the audience.
Thank you.
Let's push this a bit.
Allan and I have set up a VM
that has an application called
Hey installed.
Hey is a web load generator.
Let me bring this up.
Bear with me just a moment.
We'll add our load to the mix.
And please keep
your memes coming.
We'll see if we can knock
down our application here.
Let's just take a look.
I'm going to bring up
a terminal to this VM.
And we'll get our
load kicked off.
And then we'll see how
Kubernetes handles things.
And by the way, I'm
excited to get back
to the tab to see what
you all are creating.
ALLAN NALM: So it'll take
a minute or so for this
to come up.
And what'll actually happen is
the horizontal pod auto-scaler
will be monitoring the
load usage coming in.
And then as soon as
there's an average CPU
utilization, above 50%, you
should see a pod auto-scale.
So we're talking about
auto-scaling here
at the pod level.
But keep in mind, we've also
enabled cluster auto-scaling
for the Kubernetes
Engine cluster.
So if, for some reason, we
exceeded the resources that
are available from
a node standpoint,
Kubernetes Engine will actually
provision a new node, a new set
of nodes in our zones as well.
BRETT HESTERBERG: OK, so
let's take a quick look
and just see how
many pods we have.
We still have our
lone pod running.
Hopefully, our load generator
has started to take effect.
Let's just see here.
So we're getting close
to our target here.
We'll see if between the
audience and our load
generator, we can
ratchet this up.
What we're looking
for is a load number
coming in that is in
excess of our 50% target.
When that happens, that tells
Kubernetes Engine, Allan,
to start to scale
by adding more pods,
adding more web front ends
behind our load balancer
so that we can scale to meet
the load of our now very
popular application.
Let's take a quick look
here and see where we're at.
Still at 50.
We'll see if we can get our
Load Gen tool spinning up
a bit more.
ALLAN NALM: And these
thresholds-- you can also--
here we're using CPU.
You can also specify memory.
And we also have
an option for you
to define custom metrics,
so number of requests,
queue length, things
of that nature,
to trigger these horizontal
pod auto-scaling.
So there we go, 266%.
So we've exceeded the
threshold, and Kubernetes now
is auto-scaling the pods.
And these pods are
being auto-scaled
across the availability zones.
And there we go.
So now we have four pods that
are running within our region.
And this is the actual
state that the application
is running in.
And the controller
is monitoring us.
BRETT HESTERBERG: It looks like
our app is still up and pretty
healthy, even under this load.
Let's give it a little
more to work with.
I'm going to say that
something bad happens to,
let's just say, our
original pod here.
ALLAN NALM: Yep, so
if we kill a pod,
the controller will check
to see that, hey, I've
got only three pods
running, I should have four,
and will automatically
create a new pod
so that you constantly
have enough capacity
to serve your application.
BRETT HESTERBERG: All right,
it looks like we fired up one,
and it's a replacement.
I'm going to see if I can
give it a little more work.
We'll kill one more pod
just to see what happens.
And while we kill that, let's
go take a look at our web app.
It looks like our web app is
still living pretty healthy.
Wow.
We've got-- did
someone script this?
[LAUGHTER]
That may be worth a
coupon in and of itself.
Looks like our web front
ends are handling this load
pretty well.
Let's imagine now that we have
a problem on the database side.
So I'm going to go over
to our Cloud SQL instance.
And let's give it a problem.
I'll start by noting that our
Cloud SQL instance is happily
existing in Zone B of US
central 1, Zone Bravo.
Let's ask Cloud SQL to
failover this instance.
I'm going to initiate
a failover here.
We'll start this.
And Cloud SQL says this
operation is starting.
So what we've done here
is simulate a failure.
Typically, Cloud SQL will be
health checking our instance.
And if for some reason the
instance becomes unhealthy,
Cloud SQL will trigger this
failover automatically.
Here, because we
just want to show
what this looks like
for our application,
we're testing a failover
by manually triggering it.
So Cloud SQL thinks the failover
operation's in progress.
When this happens,
our application
attempts to connect to
the database and it fails.
So what's going on
right now is Cloud SQL
had previously provisioned
our primary instance
in Zone B. It provisioned
a standby instance
in some other zone
within the region.
It always makes sure
it's in a different zone,
a different failure domain.
Cloud SQL is making sure
that our primary instance,
our old primary instance, has
come down, won't serve any more
write requests.
And then it's bringing
up our standby instance.
After doing so, it's going
to move the name and the IP
address of our primary instance
over to the standby instance,
making it primary as well.
This is important because
to your application, when
a failover occurs,
it looks simply
like a database goes down
and then comes back up.
There's no need to
build in failover logic
to the application.
Cloud SQL is orchestrating
those mechanics itself.
After it's bringing up our
new primary instance to life,
Cloud SQL's going
off and building
another standby instance
in yet another zone
to make sure that our new
primary instance is protected.
Usually this whole
failover scenario
with Cloud SQL for Postgres
takes about 45 seconds.
So let's check back in and
see what Cloud SQL has to say.
Cloud SQL looks like
it's healthy again.
And we'll try to note
now, our primary instance
is no longer in Zone B. We're
now in Zone F, as in Foxtrot.
So we failed from
Zone B to Zone F.
Let's see if our
application is happy again.
With any luck, we'll
do a refresh here.
And it looks like we're back.
Ooh, wow.
Well done.
So what we've seen
here, Allan, is
that we've injected some
faults in our application.
And it looks like we've
successfully recovered.
We've coped with the
load from our VM,
as well as from
our audience here.
With that, let me switch
back now to our slides.
And we'll do a little
bit of wrap up.
So again, I think a
couple of key points
in our architecture here-- you
saw the auto-scaling nature
of Kubernetes Engine.
As we increased load,
Kubernetes automatically
added pods on our behalf.
You also saw how
Kubernetes Engine and Cloud
SQL handle failures.
Our application was down
for about 45 seconds
in total, while Cloud
SQL was failing over.
It wasn't down at all when
Kubernetes pods failed.
The upshot for Allan
and I is that we didn't
get a text or email about this.
This happened without us
taking any intervention.
And you all are happily
creating memes again.
So this, I think, really
speaks to the fault tolerant
nature of this architecture.
We want to wrap up today
with just a few next steps.
As a starting point, please
try this out yourself
with the code lab
that's available online.
If you haven't used
Google Cloud before,
there is a free trial for folks
who are new to signing up.
You get 300 free trial dollars.
If you created a great meme
and want to show it to Allan
and me after the
presentation, we'd
love to give you $500
more dollars to play with,
with Kubernetes Engine, Cloud
SQL, and other products.
We're early in our
conference this week.
I have a few presentation
picks for you.
First is a selfish plug
for a presentation tomorrow
about Cloud SQL, migrating to
Cloud SQL with low downtime.
If you have databases and
you want to get to Cloud SQL,
take a look at
this presentation.
Two others on the
list, Allan, are
computing with power
not previously possible
with BigQuery and
Compute Engine.
A bit of a tongue
twister, but I think
it's going to be a
great presentation.
And lastly, if you enjoyed the
nature of this presentation,
building an app
together, we think
you'll really like Cross
Platform Mobile App
Build with Firebase.
That's Dev 222
later in the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]